hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2014 award-winning science fiction movie
called ex machina
the movie begins with caleb a programmer
at search engine company blue book
winning the first prize in a
company-wide competition
he gets to spend a whole week with the
company's ceo nathan in his residence
deep in the mountains the building is
very secluded even the helicopter that
drives caleb there is only allowed to
land several miles away then he can only
walk to the front door he is greeted by
a robotic sound at the door gets his key
card to access permitted areas within
the house and gets in
caleb meets nathan who is exercising
turns out he loves to drink until he
passes out then gets up the next day to
exercise to waste his energy
nathan walks him to his subterranean
bedroom which does not have any windows
because it is actually a research
facility caleb is curious to know more
about the research conducted in the
residence but nathan refuses to tell
more unless caleb signs a non-disclosure
agreement after signing the agreement
caleb asks whether nathan knows about
the turing test which is a test
conducted by humans and computer minds
to test if the computer has enough
ability to pass as a human
he explains further that caleb is about
to be the human subject of a touring
test he is going to conduct against an
artificial intelligence android he
created named ava caleb is surprised to
learn nathan's true intentions but
agrees to do so anyway
then the first session with ava begins
she is placed within a closed chamber
with glass wall so caleb can interact
while seeing her clearly he notices that
there is a crack on the wall
through surveillance cameras and audio
feeds nathan monitors the interaction in
a separate room
after the session nathan asks how caleb
feels
he says he felt amazing and comments
about ava's impressive linguistic skills
the next question nathan asks is how
does she feel about caleb which caleb
needs to find out
at night while trying to sleep a power
cut happens in the residence the
security protocol programs a lockdown
causing caleb to not be able to open his
door
after the power is restored he wanders
around and finds a cell phone he is just
about to pick it up when nathan's drunk
voices startle him turns out it is
nathan's room caleb asks about the power
cut but he advises to not worry about it
too much as it frequently happens
although he does not know why
the next morning caleb is woken up by
kyoko a non-english servant of nathan
he attends his second session with ava
where she shows him her sketches and
asks him to tell her more about himself
suddenly another power cut happens which
brings down the monitoring system
knowing they are now unobserved ava
leans in and tells caleb to not trust
nathan
after the power is restored she normally
continues their conservation as if
nothing happened
caleb is really puzzled by the scene
when asked by nathan after the session
caleb only says that ava does not react
to the power cut
nathan brings caleb to a lab where he
made ava turns out her brain is made of
some kind of gel with the blue book
search engine itself as its software
in the third session ava expresses that
she would like to go outside and see a
traffic intersection to do people
watching
she wants caleb to take her there which
caleb implies as a date she dresses up
by wearing a dress a cardigan and socks
to surprise him then deduces that he is
attracted to her by watching his micro
expressions
after the session caleb confronts nathan
about whether he programmed ava to flirt
with him and whether it is really
necessary to create an ai with sexuality
nathan is annoyed then explains his
reasons by making an analogy with a
jackson pollock painting he suggests
that a highly functioning ai is not only
able to do things automatically but also
able to do non-automatic things such as
falling in love
in the fourth session caleb tells ava
about when he took an ai introductory
course in college where he learned a
story about mary in a black and a white
room
mary is a scientist about color who
knows all types of colors and other
related information but spends her whole
life inside a black and white room so
she never truly feels the colors the
story illustrates a computer mind which
knows all things but never truly
experiences them
once mary steps out of her room and
experiences the world firsthand that is
where her mind becomes a human mind ava
seems interested in the story then
another power cut happens ava uses the
moment to tell caleb that nathan has
been telling them lies and that she is
the one who triggers the power cut by
reversing her charging process
caleb and nathan hike to a nearby
waterfall
caleb learns that the competition is
only a disguise as nathan has chosen him
all along for his turing test
nathan knows that he is the right person
to be his test subject back in the
residence caleb observes through the
surveillance footage of ava's room that
nathan walks up to her then tears up her
sketches
furious he goes to nathan to ask about
it but he is in a very drunk state and
dances with kyoko without answering
caleb's question
the next day nathan and caleb are back
in the woods drinking caleb asked nathan
why he made ava nathan answers that ai
is inevitable it is only a matter of
when not if ai will eventually come out
he also adds that he will improve ava's
ability and create a new model caleb is
startled as he thinks able will be the
latest ai model
nathan drinks so much he passes out when
they arrive back at home then caleb
takes out nathan's keycard to access
areas in the house restricted to him he
accesses all surveillance footage and
discovers that nathan had made several
android models before ava which included
one who repeatedly asked why she would
not be let out of her chamber and hit
the glass wall until it cracked caleb
finds the previous android models inside
a closet in kyoko's room where he also
learns that kyoko is an android as well
meanwhile nathan wakes up half sober and
manages to walk to his room but cannot
find his key card to open the door caleb
appears pretending that nathan hastily
drops his key card and gives it to him
seeing how kyoko showed off her
machinery beneath her realistic skin
kayla becomes insecure if he is truly
human then slashes his wrist until it
bleeds to convince himself
at ava's fifth session caleb nudges her
to trigger a power cut he talks about
how nathan is a liar and how he is going
to reprogram ava after this test
she becomes afraid begs caleb to help
him to which he responds by explaining
his escape plan he is going to drink
with nathan until he passes out then
takes his key card and reprograms the
house's security protocols he needs
ava's help to trigger a power cut at 10
pm
she agrees with the plan caleb asks
nathan for a drink to which nathan
surprisingly refuses
however he reminds that today is caleb's
last day so he needs to tell him whether
ava passes the touring test or not caleb
says yes but seems uneasy he finally
confronts nathan about his twisted
intentions on his ai models to which
nathan argues that caleb is the one
whose mind is twisted as he saw him
slashing his wrist earlier he then takes
caleb to re-watch the footage of him
tearing up ava's drawings he admits that
he purposely did it so ava can present
the broken drawings to caleb
manipulating caleb that nathan has
treated her harshly at the same moment
nathan also installs a battery-powered
camera in ava's room so he can watch ava
and caleb's interactions even if the
power goes down nathan knows that caleb
plans to get him drunk to free ava caleb
wonders what the real test is all along
to which nathan replies that the one who
is tested is actually caleb ava needs to
use all of her intelligence either by
flirting empathizing and manipulating to
make caleb get her out of the facility
which proves she is truly a high
functional artificial intelligence
however caleb already figures out if
nathan may be watching them during the
power cuts so he already reprogrammed
the security protocols as he said to ava
earlier he changed the power cut
protocol from lockdown to opening all
doors in the residence
then time comes and as eva promised she
triggers a power cut so she can walk out
of her room
she discovers the hallway and meets
kyoko there nathan is furious by caleb's
actions then knocks caleb unconscious
before he goes out to the hallway to
confront ava she hits and pins him down
ignoring nathan's pleas to stop he is
forced to destroy one of her arms but
then he is stabbed from the back by
kyoko he fights back completely turning
kyoko off
however ava stabs him once more then
leaves him bleeding in the hallway to
die
she goes to caleb in the surveillance
room who has just woken up and tells him
to stay there
she then goes to kyoko's closet and
changes her appearance using other
android's body parts
she wears realistic human arms covers
her machines with skin puts on a wig and
wears a white dress
caleb observes her change but then
realizes he is trapped inside the room
and ava will not let him out he screams
fearfully but ava ignores him proving
she is truly manipulating him all along
after examining nathan's house ava goes
out to meet the helicopter driver who is
actually meant to provide caleb a ride
home she goes to a busy city and blends
with the crowds leaving hopeless caleb
back in the surveillance room
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching